pour ces passionnés de trains c'est un
gros chantier remplacer les traverses de
la voie ferrée de leur terminus les
traversent donc c'est les éléments en
bois qu'on voit un petit peu qui sont
autour de moi c'est les éléments les
éléments qui maintiennent l'écartement
des rails entre il en faut il en faut
quand même un certain nombre de traverse
quasiment une tous les 80 80 cm quelque
chose donc
donc voilà on est en train de remplacer
les vieilles par des l'hiver c'est
l'occasion pour l'association du musée
des transports de pithiviers de se
lancer dans des travaux de l'entretien
des locomotives à la remise en état des
voies ferrées le but du jeu de fait que
pendant l'intersaison en hiver on fasse
pas mal de travaux pour que justement le
fruit de notre travail puisse circuler
la saison suivante en espérant qu'ils ne
passent pas de problème que ce qu'on a
fait ce qu'on a fait soit bien fait et
que ça s'inscrive dans la durée
il faudra être prêt le 4 avril prochain
le dimanche de pâques le musée ne pourra
pas rouvrir mais le train reprendra ses
voyages au mois de mai dernier à l'issue
du premier confinement la fédération je
me faire touristique a négocié avec le
ministère pour qu'on ait les mêmes
règles que les transports en commun donc
nous on a le musée et le train donc
l'association va ouvrir le train dans
les règles des transports en commun
c'est on va il faut essayer de respecter
dans la mesure du possible une personne
sur deux à l'intérieur du train pour
cette reprise
il y aura deux départs au lieu de trois
les après midi à cause du confinement
des franciliens ils représentent 50 %
des voyageurs ap aux ducs au vide
l'association a perdu la moitié de ses
visiteurs de 1900 personnes en 2020
contre 6000 les autres années